In them. What does, I mean it's some sort
of chemical now, no other antigens, right?
They're, they're, they're fluid back
macromolecules. What's the liquids?
Typically it would be saline or saltwater.
And right now,
um,
what is missing from
today's vaccine protocol,
if anything in terms of diseases
we should be vaccinating for.
But yeah, there's certainly are,
um, you know, one of them is a big,
big problem among young infants,
especially premature infants called RSV,
respiratory syncytial virus infection.
What does that come from? It, it's um,
you know, it's a respiratory virus that
peaks around the same time that flu does.
So it's a very severe respiratory illness.
So this is again,
one of those vaccines
that's not a big moneymaker.
So the bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation is trying to, uh,
provide grants for supporting that one,
that that's a good one.
And then there are all the
diseases that affect poor people,
both in developing countries that even
among the point in the United States,
that was the subject of this book.
That's,
that's the next one called the
marble health. The next one.
So this is not released yet.
This is out. This actually,
this actually preceded the,
Oh look at this one now.
This book is all about poor people and
infectious diseases and that the rise of
these infectious diseases even in the
United States. That's right. So you know,
when we think about, so I, you know, let,
let this big campaign to raise awareness
of somebody call neglected tropical
diseases or NTDs.
These are the most common afflictions
of people living in poverty. Um,
I called them the most important disease.
You've never heard of their diseases like
schistosomiasis and chagas disease and
leishmaniasis and had been devoting
my life to seeing if we could develop
vaccines for those diseases in
the nonprofit sector. You know,
because the big pharmaceutical
companies just don't see,
just aren't going to take these on.
So we're trying to do in the
nonprofit sector. But this book,
the Blue Marble health book came out of
some number crunching that I did using
data from the World Health Organization
or something called the Institute for
health metrics and evaluation, which
is based in Seattle, Washington.
That found something very surprising.
And that is most of the world's poverty
related diseases are not necessarily in
the poorest,
most devastated countries of Africa,
meaning like Democratic Republic of
Congo or Central African Republic.
They're there,
but on a numbers basis,
most of these poverty related diseases
are actually in the g 20 economies,
the 20 wealthiest economies,
um, together with Nigeria,
which is not a g 20 country,
but it has an economy bigger
than the bottom three or four.
So that was pretty amazing. Amazing for
me to find that out. Because you know,
at first I didn't believe the
numbers because I said, well,
how could it be if their poverty diseases,
why are they in the 20
wealthiest economies?
And then I realized that it's among
the poor living in wealthy countries.
So the poorest of the rich today now
account for most of the world's poverty
related diseases. And what,
what's the cause of this?
So why, why the link with poverty?
So that's a great question.
One of the things I do in the
book is I asked that, well,
what is it about poverty that's making
susceptible? I don't think we really know.
I mean, clearly in some
cases, if you live in poor,
dilapidated housing
without window screens,
things like mosquitoes and kissing bugs
and sandflies can get inside the house.
Or if you look, um, in,
in poor neighborhoods,
like in and around Houston,
you see a lot of environmental degradation
or around the neighborhood you see
discarded tires that breed, it is
chipped. I mosquito or standing water.
But I don't, I don't think what, what,
what did the tires do? Discard. So yeah.
So one of the best habitats for the
mosquito that transmits Danky and Zika and
Chikungunya and yellow
fever are discarded tires.
That's what they love. So this, you
know, if you go into poor neighborhoods,
you'll see a lot of tire dumping
for instance. And that's,
those are habitats for that
eighties Aegypti mosquito,
including in southern California.
Was that when the water gets in the
tightest around a little bit of water?
That's exactly it. Yeah. You know,
I moved into a house once in a Encino
down the street from here in fact.
And um, no one had lived in the
house for about a year. And a half,
two years and the pool had not been taken
care of and I went out into the pool
and it was green and there were
schools of mosquito Skeeto heaven.
Mosquito head is so strange.
So yeah, absolutely.
You go into poor neighborhoods, abandoned
swimming pools, things like that. That's,
that's where we're getting
a number of these diseases.
We don't have very many
mosquitoes in southern California.
I mean it's really kind of amazing in
that regard. Like, well it depends.
So you know,
some counties where they do aggressive
spraying and things like that, you won't.
But many counties you probably,
probably some of the poorer counties,
poor districts you still do.
But I mean in terms of the
way it is on the east coast,
like I grew up in Boston and then
the summertime you just have fucking
mosquitoes everywhere.
They just can't get away from him.
And then I've been to Alaska,
which is the craziest place I've ever
been to in my life in terms of mosquitoes.
Right. Have you been? I
haven't been to Alaska,
but you get out of your car and they
attack you like a hoard of birds because
they only get one month of the
senior. Exactly. Yeah, they have.
So they're super aggressive and they are,
they're also very large.
The big problems along the Gulf coast
of the U s we have that aid is jipped by
mosquito and that's why I got
so worried about Zika virus.
The Gulf coast of the u s yeah.
Um,
mosquitoes and other countries
obviously contain malaria. I mean,
we've been very fortunate that that's
never made it over to here. Well, no, we,
we used to have malaria used to be
widespread in the United States. Um,
both the one that was a real killer
disease called Falciparum Malaria on the
Gulf coast and even up into
Illinois and the Ohio River valley.
We had a lot of malaria. When was that?
By five x in the 18 hundreds. In fact,
there's a whole,
there's a book written by Dickens when
he visited the United States called
Martin chuzzlewit.
No.
When he describes all of these
sickly people in Illinois and Cairo,
Illinois on the confluence of the
Mississippi in the higher river.
He's clearly describing malaria.
Wow. I did not know. Yeah.
So what stopped it? So that's
a great question. Um, we,
so there's actually a very nice book
written by a medical historian that Duke
University named Margaret Humphreys
called malaria race and poverty.
And she has a hypothesis but I think
she's onto something that um, it,
the decreased the malaria dropped in
associated with aggressive economic
development so that the FDRs new deal
included something called the Agricultural
Adjustment Act that got people off of,
off of with agrarian pursuits
and put them into factories.
Quality housing went up and
that's probably what caused
a lot of the reduction
in these tropical diseases. Remember
they're really diseases of poverty.
In fact I spent a lot of time working
in China and I'm seeing that play out
right now in China.
You know China is cuts is very,
very aggressive program
of economic development,
mostly in the eastern part of the country,
but in the southwest part of the country
go into you non Sichuan provinces.
You go back in time 75 years and you
still see those diseases. So spread.
Do you think that the best cure or the
best way to stop malaria would be just to
increase the economy of these areas in
Africa where they're experiencing it at?
Clearly economic development
is a very potent driver.
Now what it is about economic development,
we still don't have our
arms around that yet,
but economic development
is very important.
Just like for the neglected tropical
diseases we study. But you know,
unfortunately for many countries economic
development is still decades away.
So that's why, that's the rationale
for developing these vaccines.
Is it because of economic development
moves people into more urban environments
where there's less tropical diseases?
I think that's part of it.
Although now we're seeing some
tropical diseases thrive and urbanized
environments like you know, yellow
fever and Zika and dengue. He as well.
So it's not only urbanization,
you have has to be urbanization with
good planning that's not done unchecked,
that outstrips the infrastructure
in terms of water and sanitation.
So this brings me to the thing that I
wanted to talk to you about in the first
place. Cause this is what you brought
up to me. Um, when we were doing this,
a sci fi show, and, uh,
you said something to me that
has been haunting me ever since,
that the vast majority of people that
live in tropical climates have parasites.
[inaudible] vast at jar. Yep,
that's right. That's right.
There's things like Toxoplasma Gondii.
And so let's look at the,
let's look at the hit parade,
right?
The top one is one called
ascariasis intestinal roundworm. Uh,
the estimates are on 800 million people
have asked Russ Ron worms in their
bellies. Whoa. So hunter,
so more than one in 10
people on the planet,
and mostly people who live
in extreme poverty, um,
400 million have hookworm infection.
400 million have whipped warrants.
A lot of these are wormy diseases.
200 million people with scabies,
which is an ecto parasite on, on the
skin that causes terrible itching and,
and secondary bacterial infections.
Just to surmise, this is another one.
The point is every,
almost every single person who is
an extreme poverty has one of these,
what I call neglected tropical diseases.
And one of the interesting features
about them is they're very debilitating.
They not, so that not only
occur in the setting of poverty,
but I think they reinforce poverty
because they make people too sick to go to
work. They make a, they actually shape,
we can show they shave Iq points off
of kids when they have them. Well,
this is the hookworm connection to the
idea of the slack jawed dumb southerner,
right, right, right. States of America.
And now one of the things that we have
found, so ray Dalio Mahia on my faculty,
uh,
working with environmental activist named
Catherine Coleman flowers in Alabama
found that hook where Ms. Little present
and Alabama. So among the poor people,
so they understand what we're talking
about. Because for the longest time,
there was this stereotype about
people that lived in the south,
that they were dull minded,
right.
And that this could be directly
connected to hook worm infection,
which had run rampant. Right. There
was even the term given called,
they call it the germ of laziness,
then hookworm infection because
it causes severe anemia.
So if you're walking around with terrible
anemia, of course you're agreeing to,
you're to,
you're not feeling up to working a
full day and all that sort of stuff.
So hookworm was wildly president,
president in the southeastern United
States at the turn of the 20th century.
And then as malaria went down
with economic development, so,
so did hookworm infection as well.
But we still have pockets in this country.
And this was an understood at the time,
right?
They didn't know that these people
were infected with hookworm for, for,
for forever. No, up until very recently.
So the cause of hookworm wasn't
discovered until 1900 what is that?
Cause it's called indicator Americaness
the American killer as that.
And that's the name of the worm.
And this is from walking barefoot or
that goes in through the hands or enters
all parts of the body. So it's very common
to get it from walking barefoot. Right.
Which was more common in the south. Right,
right. So that's one of the diseases.
We've made a vaccine for this
now in clinical trials. Yeah.
When I found that one out, I was
like, oh my God. Well that's it.
That totally makes sense.
Because for the longest time was there,
there was that stereotype.
And then when you find out that it's
directly connected to a massive infection
of this disease, this worm, so these
are the diseases that are holding back,
people who live in poverty.
And originally I thought only in places
like the poorest countries in sub
Saharan Africa or Southeast Asia,
but now I realize it's these pockets
of poverty across the entire planet,
that people are affected by these diseases
and these diseases can be vaccinated.
That's where we're trying to prove
that we can make a vaccine against.
And there is a hooker and vaccine
right now in clinical trials. Yeah.
Just in clinical trials.